were served a podcast welcome to the
worth of food podcast with Rodrigo
Torres
Lisa Esparza and Felipe Esparza that's
right that's me Felipe Esparza the man
the myth the legend the man from Boyle
Heights
aka Batman aka the king of the cheap
shots aka the kidnapper aka the check
off with your car while you were
sleeping do all your coke or you were
laying down thinking about the future
what's up fool Felipe Esparza here the
enabler the arm the devil's advocate
these are the things that I've been calm
in the past ladies and gentlemen I'm
pretty sure everybody has been called
lots of these in the past by different
types of people but you never admit them
you know but I'm admitting right now
he's a piece of [ __ ] a four kids that
you're the bull una knows that last
Sunday or Monday Lisa's gonna have a
booger my nose
there are still an 85 for me mom will
care about how I look there with any
[ __ ] fight any argument I have my
somebody's coming around yeah you're
peeing your pants oh [ __ ] sorry so you
win the 500 changed pants what so a lot
of people might not don't like your ass
I mean they don't like you I mean they
just don't like you
there's some people out there that I
just don't like no matter what I see you
every day I just don't like you I mean I
could do a show with you and see you
every nine months but just wanna hang
out with you so could some people you
just wanna see it to show like some
people you you like I work only like I
like this guy work but then you hang out
with him after work or like you had like
a 10-minute conversation outside outside
of work by a car I realized no what this
guy's a stupid [ __ ]
he only he's only good at driving a
[ __ ] forklift he's only good at going
under a [ __ ] house and Kelly roaches
that's how he's good at some people are
just good up being a plumber we had a
guy come over a house I don't know what
the [ __ ] he was doing or a handyman
whenever a fully redeemed array in any
way so if you never didn't erase a
fuller didn't array whatever so he's
doing a good job talks a lot first of
all then at the end he told me yeah man
I asked out Bell that we just say exact
without her name Bell I just asked out I
asked out Nancy you know he asked out
here I thought Nancy do you what are you
telling me u.s. thought Nancy first of
all you to be old to be asking people
out and don't be asking people out while
you're working at my house the fool
number one just do your job get the [ __ ]
out had another guy show up to the house
okay that's creepy by the way that was
creepy man it was creepy creepy was that
he told me well youtube.com slash ATC
and you could listen to the wonderful
podcast or right now there are 42 people
listening on Instagram live and I'm also
imagine one up before we even get
started I know there's a lot of people
out there who listen to the podcast who
love the podcast who always say Tommy
wants to form a big fan okay man if
you're a big fan I'm gonna be like other
podcast then they want you to go to
their page and donate money for
shoelaces or or anything man you know
I'm not that type of comic um we made
enough money doing stand-up that we
could just do this podcast for fun and
have a good time what we're saying oh
the u.s. Auto Show squishy over there
creepin scaring Emma were self boo so
it's our ass if you listen right now on
even if you listen on Instagram this is
all I ask
I don't ask for much extra huge the
podcasts like it and share it you know
right now if you you're an Instagram go
to arm your other pages your snapchat
and just say man I just listened to the
worst of food podcast and got a little
taste
it was delicious I want the whole thing
in my mouth
it was awesome so I'm ending my
Instagram live chat now I'm gonna go to
my facebook live then Neverland
Instagram light as I go to my facebook
live immediately or I go to my facebook
to do what Co Facebook live Instagram
live will go as a regular post to
Facebook okay so so right now I'm gonna
let these people know here we're so so
what I'm asking is that if you guys
could just go to iTunes or go to
wherever you listen to the podcast and
go like it read a review or be like our
homie Alex DeLarge shut up - Alex at
large
I don't know how many card how many how
many cars it has how many cars so he
goes to it he goes into a post or every
other week after eating a burrito and
killing a 40 ounce or of beer and goes
into the Apple store and pretty much
signs up all the laptops all the iPads
are the iPhones to the werster full
podcast like they're all connected or
sell for podcast also if you don't like
the podcast just write a review I hate
this podcast that helps out too you know
so that's it boo what's up fool
we got a little toy right here if you
don't know what you a tourist I got
married by Elvis Presley and as vacatur
yeah and he has a son on the way our son
are you excited yeah you gonna be super
excited I mean my first son man I was
out there cheating no I wasn't that's
when you were loyal to the game huh
Lord's always been low to the game from
day one bro the game the game the people
I was up my first son when I had him I
was so nervous cuz you know you're young
and I felt like just saying shooting
myself or just running away or giving up
a lot of 17 when she got pregnant
right yellow 17 when she got pregnant
but when she got pregnant like everyone
knew
her mom was checking her underwear
smiling um damn you look at your [ __ ]
mouth different you must be pregnant
knows the earth [ __ ] boy
oh that's India bro like sure use my mom
will like smell underworld like like she
if she had two and she could did you
file a report figure a nurse's in her
finger her vagina to see if she's a
virgin bro that's how guru and crazy
that woman was like she says out loud
for other people too I check your
underwear
you're a loose woman now yeah if you
like poly and rocky one huh you busted I
know right
dandruff recall that that over anything
you were doing freaked out over stuff a
lot you're pregnant pregnant crazy my
diary Oh like I know you [ __ ] read
this you [ __ ] and I would write that to
her like because I knew she saw it and
what she gonna do come say hey I read
your diary you call me only had one page
of my dairy I've never heard diary I was
wanting a diary that would like the one
with a book with a little key a little
lucky nobody's gonna respect that key
and so you make your little brother or
somebody who opens up your diary man let
the whole world know like calm the worst
is dumb when you're like a drug addict
right you're a drug addict and you came
out of rehab and you're trying to go
through your steps you know step one you
admitted you were an alcoholic whatever
step two you try whatever number three
is like you trying to work on your drug
addiction now cuz number one is that you
admitted number two is telling someone
your drugs out of here number three was
you're gonna work on it but then he goes
to number four and then you're gonna
like write down a list of people you
harm it's kind of like no work homework
for yourself you know like a solvent
analysis on what the other bad [ __ ]
you've done and sometime when people
find out letters bro
or they find out you know how bad stuff
and what everybody my dad would like
that [ __ ] bro doc would he like no I
guess he liked it I stopped doing drugs
but he they liked to have smart now
flowers woke man that I realized that
you don't have to break the budget Mary
I shouldn't make no sense now if we
could take it dog slap my ass isn't that
kind of my dog after I fixed my hair bro
they didn't like the conversion to the
solid Christian they liked the
conversion of sauna Christianity they
only believe in the virgin mary rocks
with autism was called roman catholic
which seems to be so backward according
to the bible you know praying to an idle
pace I don't know but you pray to it
each other argue that it no your
interceding but it's but then it goes
it's like well you have a Catholic and
Christian right your wants the arm their
movie office space yeah I always feel
like I'm those two guys there and you
gotta fight for your religion for me
like what do you do with your lives you
well I'm the consult I'm not the camera
religion consultants will you religion
do well I put to the Redeemer and I to
intercede so you're not taking to prayer
yourself to God no III purchase the
Virgin Mary and then she take my prayers
to God Jesus take up to God that's also
so you're so basically what do you do
that's always we get the tax write-off
right now I always felt like when it
when you watch the board Joss you want a
board Joss an old-school show on Netflix
that's the way he talks to ball jostle
I'm gonna get my daughter the ball just
yeah man I didn't know that by watching
the ball just that didn't know that um
back then like if you had enough cash
you could just buy your song your way
into a pope prism to be a pope the
papacy what's up everybody this is a was
so full podcast live on are we
on Facebook as we are oh please no on
YouTube go to ATM go no you to come
become ATM you see what was that the
board rest the board I didn't know that
bro at midnight I guess now I guess now
let each other someone don't matter that
dude now you marry him right and they
should have we're confident at your back
hand back to her love you marry somebody
you're done
peace I didn't know that what was so
valuable
yeah they came from money Loire Valley
boy had to for trade for war yeah just a
like a fire was like I got a board chair
bro like he telling noticing that his
armies kind of getting kind of weak so
they fool like when I was there and had
to marry his daughter to the other guy
just to have his army yeah he took his
army but and then he got strong and then
he gave power back and him he put in his
most of his side of the family in that
Kingdom and they're pushing all the
family out yeah definitely do it how to
maintain that power though the Gambino's
did it bro
so what til [ __ ] Gotti [ __ ] it up
won't kind of well without family before
that right yeah called the boys ahead
like that brother son but in the West
before she traded him to get married or
somebody she got pregnant and they
killed the guy got her pregnant and that
baby he's hidden somewhere bro so no one
can find out that she's a she got
pregnant by somebody cuz they would like
back in the day if you're like super
like you know king and queen they were
like consummate the marriage right make
sure there was a blood spot on the bed
and all that [ __ ] a priest or somebody
from the high question I said there's
Joker and New York at Caroline's on
Sunday I said man and so religious man
if you have a woman the killer but no or
some countries they kill her I lied for
a little kill nobody but if you have a
woman they kill her have a woman baby
oh well something
in China when they help oh yeah with the
one-child policy they would only want to
have a son and then if they had a girl
they would they would kill it or there
are actually girls who didn't get killed
but they became what are called ghost
children which don't exist according to
China so they your she'll actually a
woman but he hid isn't that bite them in
the ass China now there's a big old
shortage of women police are still told
me like five years ago that they ran a
lot of women know their generation
there's they're just they are bringing
some women in from other countries not
El Salvador I like it hos we right now
Tigers person even know what happened to
that page I happen to love people on my
page they thought about being in our
begging for money bro where's the face
card or a random you mean um patreon you
don't hit me up who fool jennifer Love
Hewitt oh really yes give me up and she
said that I'm I've been I'm checking out
your profile and I've been checking out
your comedy and your statuses and then
she asked me if I wanted to join a cameo
and I went to the per-page row she looks
older dog there's a page he said hi
Jennifer this is Jen oh hi Paula this is
jennifer Love Hewitt and I just want to
say I wish you a good day and good luck
with a new promotion on your first day
of work this is a message from Lisa
Parker from Arizona and then whatever
you want bro like if we could paid her
to put up a to say what's up oh listen
to the words of who podcast do you keep
those videos and [ __ ] no more just a
message that's really you get to keep it
I think
I'm not sure how that works I should do
right I can't believe people do that
because it's like a lot of wack Packers
are doing it and that's what I mean the
backpackers on Howard Stern they make
money and like a lot of people who don't
have anything else going on that's how
they make money but you would David I
feel so weird cuz you do a few shout
outs occasionally things you really like
but you don't you really like or you'll
do it to be nice cuz somebody who can
retell my 15 year old son happy birthday
or whatever you do it for free
Thank You magic target for stuff like
that lady hit me up on Instagram and she
said that of her her her so she said
that have some little boy whatever name
is right I mean he's he's breaking my
[ __ ] show you right now make sure you
give them a bit of baby Lisa anyway so
the lady I heard you I'm gonna give us
give her a mean shoutout to-- it's need
a few more fillers about what people hit
me up and telling me ma'am we're trying
to raise these funds for this and we're
trying to raise money for that and we
really appreciate if you just share on
your page there's no third page that
they were following me know or another
one that's super when they told me that
up her son is like um she's like he's in
track and field and he's breaking
records that you know people should know
who he is
maybe should promote him on your show oh
I saw that too I'm like if your son have
yours if I have your son compete against
black people yet or anybody out of his
district you know the only the fastest
guy in that neighborhood cuz he would
cause if he's really good man I want a
son of mine Fritz Rogan or
Jim ro
rubbie all that food bro so court for
court on taxable court dog kenny land is
mine yeah but you here was this kid he's
like a cheetah man he's just like
blowing up the scene in the racetrack
district man see that guy who imitated
that guy with a you would have said him
that he would say I love to do it that's
not I'd do it good good good spirit and
I'm good with most of people math story
so people just positive man you can tell
her to [ __ ] off okay you have a nice day
too but we're gonna have to close the
door now bro you have a runner words bro
brother words he to be a security guard
from the Laugh Factory
long story short one day Jeff Garcia
comes in seller Laugh Factory try to
strike to raise a ruckus coming in there
with this fool haven't had a [ __ ] um
yeah open sleeve shirt and he ran a
denim vest a denim vest bro
baby dice looking like a bad guy the
devil looking like though looking like
the black sheep of the family on General
Hospital this fool said young man I
cannot allow you to come inside you
stirring up trouble so he kicked our
fool out and then I'll be back the next
day uh big oaf a fluffy that full bottom
a watch bro I'm Momo viral thank you for
your services thank you for kicking that
guy out here to watch but that's who
like when you get busted by the cops who
usually goes to jail the guy that's all
loud and rambunctious though gonna be
cool and calm collected this other time
the Catholics cholo for heckling broke
you stupid bro here
you cannot do that I did not used to
speaking to people or anybody bro like I
thought he was getting out to the
convenience of a stupid ad or you stupid
ass the fugato
[ __ ] stupid owns like that all louder
I got this respected blade with a prayer
dog you holding up his belly like he had
a gun they kicked have fool out his
whole family bro there were like 15 of
them and there was some older guy there
that I recognized him from related to
rug I used ups checking IDs I remember
that full place to check out ID but he
recognized me and she looked at hey man
it's really ups yeah you were the people
yeah it's like the young a young so now
who say the N word over and over and he
talked about the woods who is black he
will show you n-word now calm down young
man
my mother has Spanish shoulders bro like
calm down young man
my mom Spanish and then he walked about
he goes man you know look don't home be
man it was alright nomatter just gonna
you know let you know her man so they
kicked our fool out then he then brother
were this he that food comes back they
tell him mom
sir I'm that they tell him you have an
outstanding bill - right he'll he'll
like 76 bucks he was by he was spending
money in there so then that food thought
I swear to God I did I mention it before
but at the whole story he takes out oh
yeah like you see a brick you know how
fine a brick is right
I rented a red brick yeah well he have
five of those bro and there was not
money he took that [ __ ] out of his
pocket bro like for Briggs five bricks
like five stacks man big stacks and he
[ __ ] took I don't know what it was
$200 and throughout the wizard face he
loves
so they kicked out for out loud and
after Linda was to leave McCullough and
always put our [ __ ] right and they
weren't they thinking about doing [ __ ]
right or doing something but I'm looking
at them like [ __ ] leave him
alone and we're gonna snatch that money
what the [ __ ] were doing oh that's
that's the first thing you think about
when you thinking about killing him I
think it'll be fun grab this money and
telling [ __ ] them this [ __ ] you I was
thinking about bro grabbing that stack
jump inside with a bad leg oh yeah take
our [ __ ] trouble to Comedy Store I'm
just thinking about grabbing me one
little stack real quick but do you know
if I had a gun - huh yeah or somebody
with him had a gun dawg come on that
fool look like he was 21 years old 22
years old big deal just went down down
[ __ ] who do you think I don't wanna
pay stupid eh
he's [ __ ] just takes out you know but
funny little man and finally with a big
dog was arguing dog I could pay dog and
he puts all his money right there you
know holy $16 left to pay the rest are
[Laughter]
smoother bro there are five racks good
way to leave the bill huh
yeah what part of Brotherhood's mom what
part of Spain was she from I don't know
Morocco you from Rosie sixties they took
all that food Batman also because he
were actually to [ __ ] food over the
battle oh and then he can when he came
out of rehab he became a chef now for
that we're introduced me to that book
come iceberg slim the pimp book he gave
it to me but after that I pimp it flying
hoes were some food this week I'm gonna
be in Atlanta Georgia
June 27th through the 30th at the
punchline in Buckhead so go check that
out
San Diego California July the 3rd our
Spanish show at comedy palace
Houston Texas July 5th through the 7th
at the Houston Improv Chicago Illinois
July 13th two shows at it at the big
theater Tucson Arizona July 26 our
little desert diamond casino
kaeleen Texas who are you really are you
killing me
I'll just 1st through the 3rd twice and
funny comedy club check out Phillipos
WorldCom's last tour for all the
upcoming shows and ticket info new shows
added all the time
also man shout out to antoine from
Monte's good burger in Koreatown
we went over there and now for hooked
Lisa up with a double cheeseburger and
tater tots on this that plays super bomb
he owns that chain and he also owns this
Nick's on Beverly which we haven't tried
yet it's a high high end a nice lineup
well I had a double cheeseburger man and
I've had a lot of hamburgers and this
one comes the closer to tasting like a
fat ass White Castle makes with in and
out no and a White Castle mix onion yeah
put my head on you and they had the
strawberry shake I don't want either
shake the only fat later grilled onions
on if you have thing about going there
man hit up Antwon in Koreatown
he's the new manager there and man they
have strawberry shakes strawberry shake
is so good something you could add a
strawberry shake and they put pie crust
on it didn't taste like pie or a
birthday cake my word we were New York
City man and let me tell you man
we we had a badass Airbnb that Lisa got
for us four bedrooms
Isaac slept in an alcove
they used to be dining room probably
that was nice fellows set up nice and he
didn't even he had no trouble sleeping
all that going on around your grill next
your foot for walking a hundred thousand
steps didn't walk that much and he
didn't walk there much of Mexico well
that's probably the last time it's
already been like two years
well you in Mexico but they're a lot to
walk I'd like to see just like New York
oh dear the crypts of stuff I always
feel like Mexico dangerous men we
consider like you make a wrong corner
alley and pull they robbed us no you
just can't go away from the tourist
areas oh do you like New York right now
you can't be dipping in those old school
neighborhoods but you can be walking
into like places were that were that
we're like the birth that he was
bothered huh
yeah well you don't see Starbucks and
[ __ ] like that I know like if you see a
bull you have to wait for the places
where everyone's drinking outside
there's a bar but I was drinking outside
in lawn chairs all that [ __ ] dude really
not like stores or theaters or museums
[ __ ] that was ugly so I don't like I
don't like going to non tourist area I
don't like going to tourist areas me
neither
I don't think I like Mexico City so you
have to stay in the tourist area well
you can go to all those spots but I mean
don't where there's no people around
like a really really when it's little
neighborhood it was a beach yeah I want
to see you I want to feel - yeah I like
to see deep places if I know somebody
like yeah if I know somebody that lives
already
oh man I'll be there all day we're in
Mexico and they had The Fixer yeah after
that picture I felt like you know he
knew all the ins and outs of places but
yeah but I like to I like to what I
travel I like to live the way they live
there
you know with $5 maybe like like in Cuba
you know if everybody's eating in
people's houses and stuff like that
that's all I do I don't want to throw on
a chain
I saw another person on my friends page
to their Instagram who's living the
living the best life right now in Cuba
this crew and these two dudes and
another girl and another guy
they're in Cuba right now and they're
eating at this lady's house or the nice
restaurant supposed to be the best
restaurant in Cuba eating fat garlic
chicken the government under a boys yeah
questions cuz when Anthony Bourdain went
over there they would that was still
when they couldn't really own but it was
kind of understood that they were gonna
run this little business out of their
house it was like an understanding
between them in the government
understand like they say you can't go
you could look to Cuba they closed on
tourism but a lot of people here not
from America going over there they
flying auto and so flights still go to
Cuba they're probably going well I just
got a message from Delta that they just
stopped at the beginning of June like
they're abiding by the law and the new
law is there are no flights out so it's
got to be that you've got to go through
Canada or Mexico but if your passport if
I'm Mexico can you go over there through
Mexico or yet or kanroji go go with his
American passport yeah my friend said oh
you'd stamp it yeah you can go through
though stamp it so nobody knows you went
yeah so again when you post photo they
find out like jay-z jay-z and they got
heat from the gods Ray was open it was
also Obama was trying to change things
at that point the relationship but it
didn't get changed before he left office
and Trump just basically took everything
away but I'm surprised because I would
think Trump would want that free
enterprise happening over there you know
I mean I'm like yeah like real estate
and stuff because the first people on
that are gonna be those the ones who win
give me angel sellers are talking about
what's in there but Republican I don't
understand but the real way so Mary
tells me he's a Republican with your
Republican you can understand I'm not
gonna look at club this is a free
enterprise
Salizar down the street for more and he
went over there instead then the owner
of the comic strip were like wait a
minute I booked you were here but you
were probably a kid yeah for those
people who actually think that who are
who say the Republican who say they're
conservative who said they're for
corporate America don't like with
another company open so selling the same
[ __ ] then you change your method of
competing I feel like we're now when I
start talking about it something bad
about something that's new it's someone
else talking about it like right now so
supposedly big pants blow up in your
head you know and they blow it up and
they're destroying you but who's writing
this stuff for cigarette companies I
don't know there's a story every once in
a while and you go to the story about
that kid broke and everything yeah they
banished in Cisco scared now yes I think
their CV dealers or tobacco it doesn't
matter I think it's because of the
battery it's the I don't know if they
all use lithium batteries but I think
they're unstable these the same ones
that are in these chargers that you
can't put in check cuz those um those I
don't know but I don't know about those
on vape pens like cigarettes or
marijuana but there was with the flavor
licorice and cherry those are big big
pants everyone I've seen with those is a
douchebag bro see I'm on the freeway of
running man have everyman and then like
like understand like the vape bar really
most vapors I've seen some smaller socks
shall be where he's so bright it's like
neon light and these ugly black leather
couches like a man's like a bachelor pad
his first bet my lights are all on
there's like two black leather couches
and a glass of food not evil
stimulating your body in your mind we
don't need all that man some regular
couches man a television then the light
have drinks for us have some coffee no
make a sandwich foosball table but who
else to hang out it's just - babe
they're [ __ ] bro Manuel Martinez
date man how building vapor is gonna get
man how about you suck a dick now once
you have that joke about everyone having
a big cigar the business the car listen
man sooner or later just put a dick in
your mouth I see these dudes bro
something like 90 Magnum not so much in
Tampa but like will you pass by a
business party that's not in kind of
that nothing like tamper Cuba or Miami
like it Jackson via or or Dallas or
we're coming into a hotel and then these
fans are smoking cigarettes there's some
long [ __ ] Dodger dogs are it's
everybody didn't like those vape pins I
think they sell of vaping when you just
put your cartridge in there so you want
that big old one that looks like [ __ ]
a little brass knuckles or whatever it's
a trip do we get you high they're coming
down no space to imagine see now there's
another vape contest but to who who
makes the best design out of their
mouths yeah oh yeah yeah I see some
Asian girls get down bro I was gonna
tell you that even those vapes you don't
even know what you're smoking in those
things cuz uh Ramona had that big old
bus where we go that's right they busted
him cuz it were bootlegging vapes and
that wasn't even the original liquid in
those vapes and you're not even actually
comes from China you don't even know
what you're vaping dog soy you don't
even do but they put other she mad oil
yeah dude I'm telling you dude so afraid
of some of those extracts it actually
gave me that one that was black I just
like
I guess the first time I said some [ __ ]
I was I do this just too thick to smoke
yeah it's like I can't do this it looks
like I'm gonna hit belatedly you know
right there in downtown yeah her stuff
is legit but that's why I cost way more
money then she's either went to the old
hippie later I saw CBD was a bunch of
eggs pothead dealers right all I always
do it sounds TBD but some do this just
saw nothing about bong rips not about
where BOM pipes nothing about Babs but
they're on third and wall wholesale
wholesale only so there's a big bust
right everyone there who sells pot shut
down through the cops showed up they
shut down but they everyone ran and then
and and ended up not being a drug bust
and you know being a CBD pen bust a lot
of foods out there were fake CBD and ha
somebody went there was a custom one big
and tone of word where's your audio
distributors huh oh hell yeah and then
they were bootlegging that supposedly
that good brand so then they're jacking
them and they know their sales are going
down and all that yeah just like when
you look to the valley or you go to
Colorado and they tell you we got me at
that oh jeez Louise the 13 and it ain't
not really been I don't remember being
purple they call it King Louie like they
all about how about that bud that um
it's just it looks a little bird but
it's like it's round but it's like it's
not really like nuggets but it's just
round bro do like Nuggets bro but
they're not like nugs
they look like more they look more like
those bugs
data be real selves to eat all those nug
those figner no I'm good we did lose my
chuckle drugs and let you break it up it
doesn't really break up like regular
nugs it's just solid bro and that's the
man's no good hey what is brown - that's
a [ __ ] you make edibles at it
that's the stuff bro let you see a
bicycle could I walk with you that way
that way if somebody doesn't really know
what's up dude but a lot of people you
know they'd say they know what's up come
around with like [ __ ] on the best
broiler wouldn't that you're blazing and
there is a by sahagun article
love was the only one so right you know
I said that when that no you know
walkway to the lab wait no time and then
I first start hitting a broad little he
had to go back to work read a size I
like it when people hit good as we
waited till the original Diablo they
haven't hit good even while they cough
all nasty does dab status what's up fool
New York City shout out to Roger par
from rogue management or OG u e
management and Chris Salinas from ICM
that would showed up to the show and
said what's up for also man a big shout
out to the homies Covino and rich Covino
and rich I was having a convener ratio
those guys had a big event so many big
events that were happening at the bat uh
at uh at the wrong cut in New York City
there was a Steve Trevino he was
somewhere I don't even know where but he
was there sure hoping that he showed up
I don't know where he were performing
that I just know that Momo Rodriguez out
there helping um and I'm glad he's there
and they have the scag fest his homeboy
was going yeah very weird and you were
wearing a date I told about this man he
was a weak-ass date because it so you
lied the table Airport airplane what the
[ __ ] else are you lying about dog and I
want the way
[Music]
no where's the old Baron they will judge
her that's how he was to his lady girl
cool mystery girl showing up at the
airport and I was like wait a minute she
didn't just meet him at the airport and
I was like wait a minute maybe she spent
the night with him well where was she
all night we were all together all night
and she was that I guess she went he
sent her in a car to go to the hotel
instead of like bring her backstage we
had room back I ran I ran back to the
merchant that's when I seen her and then
I'm all what happened here ladies oh hey
senator Elena uber yeah it's just really
weird like I told you he did weird cuz
Isaac goes where is Johnny going I said
I said I guess he's going with Rodrigo
but you were done finishing them I
follow my food truck right cuz we were
about to leave Caroline's yeah we had to
get them to unlock the door to get out
but you were still down there and then
Johnny's like okay I'm just gonna stay
with Rodrigo and then we started walking
away and johnny was walking away and I
was like aren't you gonna wait for
Rodrigo isn't he coming he's like I
didn't find out I got up to the top well
we're gonna go alright you guys ready
yeah I'm ready
rightful let's go oh no I'm gonna stay
here I got date the girl even Isaac no
he's acting weird he's like well what
did he say and I was like I don't know
it kind of trailed off his answer was
just a good Bricklin already go yeah man
also man I was here wasn't later no so
Cesar Robles he's single now he's single
now he was so full also man if you get
there no man I was on the Howard Stern
wrap-up show with John Hines in Gary
Belafonte I'm not sure they're buying
[Music]
dinner but is there a party tell about
it
some people say della bait there's a lot
of different celebrities who read those
IDs you know and they got to do the
little wild as morning show with a bunch
of Spanish speakers Megan the make out
of the Puerto Rican show everybody there
within the whole world all over the
place there were five people having
different conversations yeah even a guy
would the producer the guy in charge
how did here was no way I was a cop in a
Casio
[Music]
what's up fool me Rodrigo were like
pound for pound the finest people in the
subway and every subway I swear to God I
did not see anybody fatter than us
unless least I was in the subway to
other but he would have won but I don't
know man that fool I mean I took a lot
of subways and I took a lot of walking
but I really saya talking us that his
now his his fixer the guy who brought
the guy who show he showed up with and
they were talking about you know talking
about yeah yeah we'll catch a train to
Brooklyn he was on the train to Brooklyn
man he lived the train to Brooklyn he
never so you at the sky festival after
party I was there at the at that last
little show all the best goddamn show
right yeah did you see them perform I
seen the last of it just because I had
to take off and you said bill was
performing playing drums and yeah dude
what's the name Sam triple he's the one
that got me in and then I was like I
just want to make it by good
just one over there said hello for about
45 minutes and craft was a lot of people
they're all out dudes mostly dudes it
was a couple chicks here the skanks
couples gay there are people there with
like big dreams
there was like like a lot of people who
look like [ __ ] you know at the dice man
do but if he was a trash man I was out
of food man swear huh it's a yeast ghost
dogs that whole attitude but dude who a
sponsor with that skank fest there's
like a CBD company that's it that's all
I seen on their billboard with all those
shows that the worst part of the
response they had shows on all three
levels in the basement in the main room
and then up top that's what's up fool
what's up fool I think our Benji
audition for that he didn't get it he
was all bummed bro oh I just shouldn't
do what Gabe is like yeah somebody has
tape he must have said what it's bad is
it
[Laughter]
what's up fool Roger pause showed up I
said that also little to the funny
Latino bro oh hey I'm gonna catch up
with you on the second show oh I can go
my son just graduated then I have
another one hey I'm right here the
person I don't talk we have to go now I
will tell you about but you'll figure it
out
yeah we're busy man I did a lot of press
and then I had an audition for Silicon
Valley and I myself taped myself I said
they live so if you don't see me on the
show let me didn't get it
alright I went to my acting class
yesterday I killed it I killed my row I
was a reading for Marlon Brando in that
movie the the fresh man remember Matthew
project but he's on the phone and
Matthew Roddick you're talking to him
and he's on the phone talking about what
we're talking about
heart we're talking about these Celtics
these salty cracker making me thirsty
no yeah man sobbing I've been going to
acting class for three years now getting
ready for that big row three years
consistently consistently man and I know
I'm getting better now I'm more focused
I'm ready I'm really on Masada what's it
doing a better job memorizing your lines
which is good no one else I got the the
beats talent man yeah what's up for the
old man
what was the mmm podcast chillin dude we
got 56 episodes I recorded two that I
lost because I have a new sequencer and
I didn't know how to use it on on the
double mic and I [ __ ] up two
recordings were only have one version of
one person on there so I could have a
shell those talking my little guest back
but they're all up there and you can go
to my website too you can link from
there Rodrigo Torres jr. calm we have a
Spanish show tonight well Spanish you to
learn so though you're watching this on
the youtube.com slash ATC we have a show
tonight in Spanish at the Comedy Store
at 10:30 p.m. that's Benji hosting right
Benji is hosting and we might get a
little dog another rescue named Henry
Chinaski
that's going to be couldn't you guys
already got him like a selection a
pitcher yeah I think we want we know
which one we want and he's he's
recuperating from some surgery on his
penis
he had a mass was too big that's some
sort of non cancerous mass but he was
abandoned at a shelter okay
he's looks just like yeah but he's tell
your world no no teeth he's a boy
they spayed now and everything they took
care of his surgery he's really healthy
now but they ended almost ready for
adoption
yeah full house he wanted another one
but she got adopted while we were in you
know a squishy Lulu I'm happy for her
but I'm sad for us and the rabbits have
Grover lugar four legs six days without
with other dogs in the rabbits and
luckily we had someone watching them
Shelly one up and but I guess the dog
just sleeps are the most dogs sleep all
day unless you they are like doing stuff
with them but if they're so you're not
going anywhere or doing stuff with them
they'll just snap out you guys didn't
get tired from all the walking in New
York I I did I took a nap a day but dude
on Friday night I'm used to that though
every day I worked I walked twice to
walk to work because I didn't like to
take the subway and it was I had to walk
to the subway anyway so I just walked to
work but if you want to have a good time
man leacy gonna start having the
neighborhood app podcast no I'm not
that's a good idea
it's about people who we are not uh
again living in a neighborhood that's
not in it like in our city or anywhere
go to your neighborhood app and next
door next door the average girl next
door next you can hear all the
complaints from homeowners join for your
neighborhood and they have to accept you
but you'll be win no they just accept
you but it's a forum it's a people post
stuff hey what day is trash day or hey
people complain about crazy [ __ ] that
car that's been sitting there yeah
that's up of that car that's been
sitting there for three days on with
Westchester Street or whatever can we
get it towed I'll call this please the
this is the police officer for your area
you know all that stuff but a lot of
times well fireworks or target talk [ __ ]
about somebody thought that part target
was selling fake firework or selling
fireworks so smart about showed the
picture like I was really disturbed to
see this it was poppers but they didn't
know and they were telling him there is
enough fireworks and then the tool to go
down bro
yeah they don't take the post down they
leave you roll a if you're wrong about
five words you should take the [ __ ]
pose for them to get it taken down
though so stupid so focused and then
people complain about the taco vendors
the street vendors that are coming in
like this is what I move to LA for us
better than ever I want not in my
neighborhood they don't want it in my
neighborhood and they're blocking the
street
you mean the biggest street nobody walks
on nobody walks out there the valley
come on nobody watches and there's
something that all great RV just parked
in a busy street nobody's even they're
born RV right but it's also like where
are we gonna go back housewives have too
much time on their hands some but it's
also a lot of Republicans who want to
insert their politics so well it's cuz
accrue it's because of our governor it's
because we are in California and there
was one guy sold his house it was moving
to Arizona and he couldn't have been
happier you're so happy why Arizona I
was like yeah good I'm so sick of you by
the way but I didn't say that but it's
just like get off already Nate kept
saying oh so glad just sold just closed
down the house and I can't wait to get
out of these city and all this stuff and
everybody's like why the [ __ ] are you
dumping all over got it you know you are
you've been trying to leave for four
weeks and you won't shut up about it
just go people what methods all the
traffic Royces be let that's a rule it
off stop complaining
it's always been to your house as soon
as you start getting into Monterey Park
itself so people don't plan their trip
who are complaining like if you plan
your trip you know there's gonna be
traffic you know what's how you're gonna
get there stop [ __ ] cried a little
[ __ ] take a train and they have a train
from sammartino to Riverside or late
there's white people who move in like
from other parts of America and they
move to California or our neighborhoods
ago there's no culture here what the
[ __ ] [ __ ] go outside
hey that's why I'm here to put your flag
down there's no culture here back there
no good Mexican restaurants how long you
been in California you son of a [ __ ]
his victory Boulevard we're all about
waiting back to Pittsburgh people like
that are a drag especially what you see
that Riverside like well it's funny that
you guys mentioned that somebody sent me
an email to join the neighborhood things
oh really
yeah that's well shown you
I thought you just looked at don't even
talk to you die it's annoying if there's
some really good neighbor the neighbor
lady from next door
and she sent me a message on facebook I
don't know how she found me Doug this
lady's a [ __ ] fool and she's summer
house we'll finally peace out but uh hi
neighbor
I don't know if you realize that your
sprinklers have been I don't know why
she sounds like Gracie but I don't know
why your sprinklers have been going on
for hours but anyhow telling me the
story buddy to have a dog and the dog be
some Asian guy no ham bro and a dog
called he color carves and it just took
that fool it is what you do go home tell
my dad and there was if you take the dog
food TV just buy a dog and put a roof
right over like it's the Wawa West them
the way they were not say about Bendix
they did a whole campaign for like a
year dog busting all these people don't
you can't do not anymore
I think it a lot of people my
neighborhood watch the dog or have a
life simpler sometimes you gotta get you
got to get them shots cuz they they bite
you they can give you [ __ ]
on top of like you know yeah yeah all
your vaccinations like I had a lot of
paperwork for squishy to prove she had
to be spayed and if you're not you know
you have to have your dog spayed and
that's why a lot of people don't want to
register there and that's why a lot of
dogs and cats get sick because they go
outside there's another crap or whatever
and they pick [ __ ] up from that dude
it's a how to get worms and dog cancer
sometimes you get they'll be like
raccoon poop or grass that has had
raccoon poop even in the last seven
years that the larvae can can live over
where the eggs can last on the raccoon
poop and you can get that's how dogs get
heartworm there's a homeless people
there by the neighborhood like run the
corners like not in a corner but there's
a spot like about a mile way my way
around mile and a half away it's a river
bottom and there's a bunch of congregate
there and every summer they start a
little fire we have one to hang out at
the end of the street not even a mile
into the mile but there needs to be more
under the bridge but this one I'm like
an RV and then I got a big ol trailer
bro to connect it to it then there's
another hot car in front of it where one
do slit sleeper yourself but that's over
under the 118 that's like way over under
the freeway it's Aqueduct oh yeah but
that's by the yeah what do you guys feel
about that [ __ ] kick him out of there or
what hey they bother nobody
I feel like do a little man's dog like
that I would go with that I've you know
Gracie think about the abbess bro
I people they're not supposed to be on
residential streets for more than a
certain number of hours or a number of
days so there there are rules in certain
areas but some people are realizing they
live in areas where you're allowed to
have an RV parked there on the street
for a while you know and so you can't
call anybody about it but but if they
have I feel like it's a big city and
you're gonna and the times are changing
and you're gonna have people living in
RVs in their cars you just have them
already but I don't know about kicking
him out Gracie was talking about she had
a good idea the other day she said what
if we just had like a big lot or a big
field of that you can turn into a space
for people because not everybody wants
to get off the
Street and be in a shelter or being
low-income housing a follow rules and
all that stuff there are people that's
why they there are people living in
their cars and living in their RVs and
living on the streets they are not ready
to transition into housing and they're
going to cause problems or be violent or
whatever or be addicts and they're not
going to fall into the kind the category
that can go into these shelters so she's
saying why not just have like a big lot
or a big place where you know big open
space where these RVs can stay and rest
area yeah almost like a rest area
whatever just stupid I'll just stay
there well they know baseball right
there are places the Santa Barbara I was
reading an article about that they have
certain like stores or churches that
will allow people to park in their
parking lot overnight so it's a little
safer as well they sure what happened
but you don't want people dumping and
you don't want people you know if you
had like sanctioned areas where okay
this is where you can dump your [ __ ]
it's a filth in the eyesore there's a
lot of people yeah but like if they're
gonna be homeless they really don't care
about all that right right it right
there if you go off the five freeway
right there when you get off on Broadway
if you look to your right there's a dude
living there you know how they have like
those stairs that go under but it
doesn't go under nothing but there's a
fence it's blocked off but it's like Ivy
on the fence he actually has a sign on
there this is private property keep out
but to buy the when you're going on the
110 north and you know you passed by
three Turtles to get to the splits off
to the 110 to a55 north in the 101 right
there above the third tunnel there's
like a whole name on a whole camping
area right there they painted in those
it looks almost like concrete little
houses right by the police academy right
yeah I think haze broke you know McClure
that foot had summer camp at Griffith
Park and then like when they were going
hiking they found a family but they were
living there yeah camped up in the
riverbed and then they were having a
fight the cops showed up and they had to
call the cops because we are doing their
camp nearby but you know it was like a
domestic violence thing MySpace living
in Griffith Park yeah but it's a but
it's a problem though dude and then like
Aviva Cynthia's City of LA he's gotten
like dude like almost a billion dollars
in funding don't shoot that's another
thing they're not doing anything with it
but even when they do build a housing
not everybody wants to be placed and
then and people don't want them in their
neighborhoods and others a homeless
shelter beam bill in Venice and they
were even complaining over there yeah
there we get notified and we get
notified when there's gonna be like a
low-income housing unit built or
something in the neighborhood and then
people get all pissed where the [ __ ] do
you want them to live you know you don't
want to live in their streets but you
don't want to build in low-income
housing nearby because it's gonna bring
your property value down and only
property value just doesn't go down like
that it's just always and these people
will church church every Sunday and
still evil on the internet like I don't
go to church every Sunday so I don't
have to be nice to anybody but you go to
church every day you pray you get down
on your knees and you take cheeses and
you forgive Jesus but you store [ __ ]
don't [ __ ] out of here a Bible instead
of a nobody still [ __ ] man like you
need you mean you mean to people you
don't want to help people you forget the
most important part of the Bible charity
goodwill to unto man they'd rather send
those little dollars and cents over to
Africa now I know I should pardon that
man like I similar to Africa yeah I
forget here dog
all these people who who lead with love
bro these people who who won you don't
need money for they could go to a third
world country and build housing for the
poor people
there's trash to be picked up on your
street or they're gonna go in and clean
up clean up whatever they going to how
I'm clean up here is never a [ __ ]
Oh totally I got a stack of trajan
homeless guy laughs pick it up no
they're gonna go if the selfies are
better than Africa
people rather like a cloud people rather
like listen they get mad when something
is going viral that everybody's getting
behind you know like oh that's like a
[ __ ] up it's just a the [ __ ] up
photo of the week whether it is for the
for the Democratic side or for
Republican side just say the [ __ ] up
photo of the week and everybody's
showing it broke just say that
everybody's showing it like Beyonce
showed it but now your fans are how come
you haven't showed it [ __ ] already seen
it my page is a comedy page alright
first and foremost if I can promote a
comedy show I'm not gonna promote the
[ __ ] up [ __ ] picture of the week
because nothing to help nobody what
everyone likes people to feel sorry for
me
I want to see people fighting on my
[ __ ] page with a photo so [ __ ] that
photo I know the bad thing that happened
but happens every day it's been
happening every day except for you
normally people died in the
concentration in the camps here in a
border brawl
you know how many people died in up
camps oh and they're in the no camps
that are in Mexico there's some people
right now bro who I cook who are coming
in through from Europe know who are
going to who are killing in boats in
Africa paying $25,000 and going to
Europe where the main cohort is over
there and then from Europe they take
that boat all the way to Mexico Colombia
that bull goes to Colombia and then from
Colombia these immigrants they trying to
make it to United States
alright okay a lot of them are from from
Africa the Congo Ivory Coast the
cheapest part of the wheeler the poorest
part of Africa Nigeria and they made our
way to Mexico now Mexico and not dealt
with that many African American Africans
in their life right or left this many
many different types of immigrants so
these people don't even know how to
speak Spanish bro but they know how to
say now no I comida para nosotros or we
are they know how to say we haven't ate
in two weeks
so where's their words are supporting
now man we only want you only what you
really care about the photos that go
viral hell yeah that's the one thing it
like so just let you know man whatever
problem
immigrants are having here in America
it's worse for [ __ ] than Mexico
but you're now claiming that [ __ ] you're
not opening up your bedroom - um my mom
bro they used to be like bicep
passing-by bro like hungry bro I'm all
become a little taco a little kiss a
deer to go yeah they my Bobby my dad be
like okay and I will not tell you
something bro
people say everybody's are all [ __ ] up
there used to be some all [ __ ] up
right there on Echo Park right there by
the by the [ __ ] is that by the Libya
Boulevard MacDonnell's on Scott by the
Taco Bell there was like 10 Jews passed
out in a row bro yeah like after they
realized they weren't getting picked for
jobs yeah drown their sorrows way to
drive by to a bruise at them good job
sweep it somewhere clean up your act
what's up next your dog it's gonna be
July Lisa where's our guest I don't know
you got lost I didn't even get a message
I told you how to feel yeah I wasn't
gonna show up Tuesday July 9th leave a
little jokes Lisa it'll be in the house
I'm not gonna mention who we had today
but Lisa what is your next show show
what self we'll shout out here the big
story that came out with that girl suing
I'm a PA no but I know the the dogs got
released over the weekend right now you
know what
the dog would the story came out right
oh yeah man those dudes were like
hardcore purrs purrs brought like emails
bro me to the now so hard right now were
they how would you sell it to a
co-worker bro not to get hung good data
you would even say that to a co-worker I
already said the co-worker back in the
day before there was phones I wouldn't
walk up to a co-worker and grab her
shoulders even though I wanted to stop
I never I never even if I would've had a
crush on some they never knew because
they were told nobody I never told
nobody I liked her this person I never
said anything bad by anybody and then
they were joined conversations it would
be too embarrassing if that [ __ ] never
came back and people said something
about it I wonder we go nobody you [ __ ]
yeah [ __ ] all that hey you remember that
one one time you better tortillas he
went off on a grown Twitter they didn't
want to take his advances oh that's
right I remember right like to call her
like dude like you fat this and that
yeah it's always there was a violent
reaction that first whoa bro like you
try to throw the sword out they didn't
want to do yeah and then it call you a
[ __ ] [ __ ] I just don't want you can't
happen like what happened to shrill at
the end of the last time yeah just trash
her like that happens a lot of happens
online the people tell you or hit you up
hey you should go out sometime or
whatever hey I'm in a relationship or
whatever Oh [ __ ] it ain't like that you
think you're all bad just turn your gas
pools
yeah it's insecure people who can't take
no for an answer and then they get off
you have to take knows that's what my
like you can't win
you couldn't even like you could have no
choice of my own so you can't even like
some babies like I'm just liking your
page they looked over to me I will give
you a guest spot dude and that's dude
see that's that something sucks
especially the social media you give
somebody they think it means something
else it just means what it means a
little like eight keep doing a chip off
sacks
we got one like it's like come on man
and then you're gonna turn it into
something else hey what are you getting
in wait look at my photos if you're
[ __ ] your profile private [ __ ] that
to get all mug like I don't get that
either dawg why even private but
whatever everybody has a right to do
whatever they want to do yeah some
people don't want that [ __ ] their life
may be all math we'll be getting mad huh
but then they be trolling when they're
private too though it's like what the
[ __ ]
oh they love trolling when their privacy
don't is that really I don't think you
should pray you shouldn't be trolling if
you're not if you're not if you're not
public that's the best way broad
I do it with a Billy Crystal for face
but that's even creepier to somebody
going through your [ __ ] it's like yes
quite a math one now
inquiring minds rasa what some fool
Felipe Esparza right here don't forget
man I'm gonna be in Atlanta Georgia this
week San Diego California July 3rd off
Spanish show at the comedy pilot Houston
Texas your life 5th through 7th at
Houston improv Chicago Illinois July 13
to show that the big theater Tucson
Arizona July 26 Sahuarita desert diamond
casino killed in Texas August 1 through
through the 3rd twice at funny comedy
club check out all these dates at
philippi WorldCom's last tour also men
shout out to Jorge Perez he's having a
show at the ballet room on June 28th at
the is George Perez and friend so that's
Friday this Friday so it'll be satisfied
thing a mega man will be there of course
Friday the 28th yeah so George Perez
from joint Perez stories is having a
show at The Comedy Store if you got want
to go to that show go hit him up but Tim
moderno I think I've been practicing
getting the band together and [ __ ] and
recording an album you know talking to
Rick Rubin yeah man Rick Rubin a
Quintana and I shout out to you know
what was the coolest thing in New York I
mean the besides like going up was the
freak show dude at Coney Island freak
show I love a freak show anywhere I go I
never seen a sword swallower I saw a
difference water electricity girl and
the guy that we saw in Venice I was a
badass chick too then we saw wolf boy in
Venice I love freak shows I grew up on
freak stuff my grandmother used to clip
out pictures of freaks and little boys
Escobar came up bro I have never seen a
[ __ ] that looks like that we're enough
rate to a free show with my mom they had
a bad
plain there yeah a bad name in the
background a hold the whole time we were
there and they were good or pretty like
kind of like a surf rock well the New
York freakshow the Coney Island freak
show those have always been people who
like yours usually live in the East
Village or that you back in the day they
did and they were part of the punk scene
and stuff and the artists seen artists
community and so that was just there
like side job that they did we saw that
guy who stretches yeah well the
contortion contortionist yeah I love all
that man they grow Stefano who lays on
the nails pretty good too
when our we were there for the oh my god
it was so freakin hot and so packed at
Coney Island could ever have the mermaid
festival thing a Pride Festival I
thought it'll be just women they're
mermaids
laughs [ __ ] sea horses got in there I
use it was hard virgins
between already hot dogs a one hot dog
am I the best thing I had There was that
carving carving ice cream bacon all
wrong Isaac had toasted white cloud with
batter be like them no price I've got
him there like that and could last I
went to Coney Island but dude that
pescado pits you should put those old
clams in there that was like I was like
I thought they were like that that one
time no other favorites were right
franklin's well Nathan's ad I didn't
know they had a whole separate barn and
though they used to be mixed in with
their regular restaurant that's all to
the side and then they got that
independent went on to the side Isaac
loved him it was so but that place is so
huge now Coney Island they have rise
they ever the haunted house food
everywhere fried they are proposed under
people and fried Oreo manatee I want to
fry order right now we're so fortunate
of the wonderful Park and also man if
you love the show let us know on Twitter
man if you listen to the show all 70,000
people listen to the show
Twitter it man snapchat it hashtag what
so food park and they don't know you're
out
a raffle thank you